[Musique]
il était censé nous sortir du pétrin
dans pandémie dans les études les vaccin
s'avérait très efficace vacciner ça rime
avec et aimer ça rime aussi avec taxi
par et et
puis il ya eu les variants la quatrième
vague les hôpitaux qui se remplissent à
nouveau
de quoi miner nos espoirs d'un retour à
la normale
les vaccins contre la copie 19 sont ils
à la hauteur
je m'appelle gaël lucia berthoud je suis
journaliste dans votre émission de
sciences préférées je suis dans la
quarantaine je viens montréal j'ai reçu
deux doses de vaccin contre la copie de
19 à l'animé et à la mi juillet
et comme vous peut-être je me demande
maintenant dans quelle mesure je suis
protégé
d'abord quel est le risque que j'attrape
la coved 19 même si je suis vacciné
pour le savoir je me suis rendu à québec
où des chercheurs analysent on continue
les faits des vaccins contre lacko ville
l'épidémiologiste gaston de serres de
l'hyène spq a accepté de me donner un
petit cours de statistiques
dont d'être tendance en moi j'étais
vacciner deux fois vous avez
vraisemblablement été vaccinées deux
fois oui si on veut savoir maintenant
quel est le risque ont attrapé la coved
19 par rapport à quelqu'un qui n'est pas
vaccinée comment on fait ça bon alors
évidemment quand on veut voir comment
fonctionne un vaccin jusqu'à quel point
il est efficace on doit toujours qu'on
parlait ce qui arrive à des vaccinés à
un groupe équivalent de personnes non
vaccinées donc c'est vraiment la
réduction de la maladie chez les
vaccinés par rapport à ce qu'on trouve
chez les non vaccinés
si on prend les chiffres du québec pour
le mois de septembre près de 4800 4go
vides ont été diagnostiqués chez des
personnes doublement vacciner et
environs 13800 chez des gens non
vaccinés pour bien voir la différence de
risque entre les gens vaccinés et non
vaccinés il faut rapporter ces cas-là au
nombre total de gens vaccinés près de
six millions de québécois et non
vaccinés un peu plus de 2 millions ça
permet de calculer les taux d'infection
dans les deux groupes pour les comparer
en septembre il était presque dix fois
moins élevé chez les vaccinés
quand on parle par exemple de 10 fois
moins de risques ben ça correspond
effectivement à une réduction de
90% delà du risque de la maladie alors
si par exemple on dit les gens qui sont
non vaccinés ont un risque de seins chez
les vaccinés on aura un risque de 10
pour un nombre équivalent de personnes
donc on va voir réduit de 90 pour ça
90% c'est l'efficacité vaccinale que
l'institut national de santé publique du
québec lee 1 sp qu à mesurer tous
vaccins confondus
en analysant les infections
diagnostiquées entre mars et septembre
l'efficacité a un peu diminué contre le
vario delta à + 83 % chez ceux qui ont
reçu au moins une dose d'un vaccin à arn
messagers et 66 % chez ceux qui ont eu
deux doses d'astrazeneca
est ce que ça veut dire que moi comme
personne vaccinée comme un individu j'ai
dix fois moins de risques d'attraper la
coville parce que chez baxi vous avez
dix fois moins de risque que quelqu'un
qui est non vaccinés effectivement donc
la vaccination diminue clairement mon
risque d'attraper la co vide mais si je
la trappe malgré tout est ce que je
risque d'être très malade
une étude menée au royaume uni a montré
que les gens vaccinés qui attrapent la
coved sont plus souvent asymptomatique
et quand ils sont malades ils ont des
symptômes moins nombreux moins graves et
qui durent moins longtemps
ceci dit il ya quand même des gens
vaccinés qui tombe gravement malade
si on regarde non pas les codes
d'infection mais les hospitalisations
plus graves l'efficacité des vaccins est
encore plus grande les gens vaccinés ont
au moins 13 fois moins de risques d'être
hospitalisées que les non vaccinés y
compris s'il attrape le variant delta et
33 fois moins de risque de mourir de la
coved
c'est clair que ce qui est le plus
critique c'est la protection contre la
maladie gras on une proportion de gens
qui aboutissent à l'hôpital qui est
beaucoup plus élevé qu'avec nos autres
virus respiratoires et c'est ça qui est
la principale cible de notre sauveur
programme de vaccination prévenir ces
hospitalisations cd c'est qu'on voit
avec la coved et qu'on ne voit pas de
façon équivalente avec les autres virus
respiratoires pourtant la proportion de
gens hospitalisés avec l'aco vide qui
sont vaccinées a augmenté ça peut
paraître inquiétant mais en fait c'est
mathématique
si on a une population qui était 100% à
vacciner et qu'on a des corps mais
évidemment on aurait 100 % nokia qui
seraient vaccinés là on voit bien là que
oui c'est normal d'avoir une proportion
élevée d'individus vaccinés parmi les
corps lorsque la couverture vaccinale
est très élevé
l'hiver dernier le québec a choisi
d'espacé les doses de vaccins
disponibles au delà des recommandations
des fabricants pour offrir rapidement
une première dose à autant de jeunes
possible
il s'est passé huit semaines entre mai
le dos est-ce que ça fait une différence
en septembre
lien explique hu a comparé l'efficacité
des vaccins selon l'écart entre les
doses pour celui de feu the big one tech
que j'ai reçu on voit qu'avec trois ou
quatre semaines d'écart il prévient très
bien les hospitalisations à 92% et
l'efficacité grimpe quand l'écart
s'allongent pour atteindre 99 % chez
ceux qui l'ont reçue à huit semaines
d'écart vraiment rendez vous là plus que
s'améliore avec le temps pour comprendre
pourquoi j'ai rencontré andrés fine sin
qui étudie la réponse immunitaire au
virus de l'aco vide et aux vaccins on
dirait que les suisses portent là ça se
passe à peu près deux mois après la
première dose puis quand même maintenu
dans le temps
au contact du virus ou du vaccin notre
corps se défend avec des anticorps et
des cellules comme les lymphocytes ce
qu'on appelle la réponse cellulaire une
riposte qui s'affine avec le temps
ce qui arrive c'est lorsqu'on choisit
intervalles entre les doors c'est qu'on
laisse plus est un système immunitaire
des peaufiner sa réponse est donc on
pense que ça pourrait affecter
potentiellement là le type d'anticorps
l'affinité des anticorps la puissance et
sa technique on va revenir et même la
réponse cellulaire des travaux menés par
plusieurs équipes de chercheurs dont
celle d'andré screen ci montre qu'un
intervalle prolongé entre les doses
provoque une meilleure réponse
immunitaire qui pourrait aussi durer
plus longtemps
et c'est important il ya des centaines
des milliers de québécois qui ont reçu
c'est régiment vaccinale autre manière
le long terme entre les deux et je peux
vous dire que la réponse immunitaire qui
générait et franchement extraordinaire
si je me suis fait vacciner c'est pour
me protéger mais aussi pour protéger les
autres autour de moi mes parents mes
amis mes collègues
alors si j'attrape la coved malgré mes
vaccins est-ce que je peux la
transmettre à d'autres personnes
j'en ai discuté avec andré veillette qui
participe à un groupe de travail fédéral
sont les vaccins contre la copie 19 on
n'a pas encore de réponse tout à fait
clair mais c'est clair qu'une certaine
protection contre
de la trappe et puis aussi de le
transmettre aux autres mais c'est
probablement pas au complet
dans une étude menée chez des
travailleurs de la santé en écosse
l'hiver dernier des participants
vacciner puis infecté ensuite ont
transmis le virus à des membres de leur
famille mais trois fois moins que les
malades non vaccinés
si les gens là donne ados qui vont
prendre aussi donner moins de virus et
on sait que la quantité de virus qu'on
donne
ou qu'on reçoit est aussi très
importante alors si quelqu'un donne des
plus faibles doses de virus à son voisin
parce qu'ils ont moins de virus parce
qu'ils ont été vaccinés à ce moment là
ces gens là risquent moins d'être
malades
au printemps j'avais fait un reportage
qui m'a marqué sur les séquelles qu'on
peut garder la maladie ce qu'on appelle
le syndrome post co vide ou la copie de
long
j'avais rencontré anne bearer une
médecin de montréal qui a eu la qu'ovide
en décembre et qui était encore épuisé
et essoufflé bonjour
aujourd'hui neuf mois après son
infection elle ne va pas mieux ils les
médecins ne savent toujours pas pourquoi
je t'aime à travers ces
mariages
je suis brûlé si j'attrape la coved
malgré le fait que je sois vacciner est
ce que je risque aussi d'avoir des
séquelles comme ça c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui peut être très
dévastateur mais les évidences suggère
que les vaccins pied prêt viendrait
probablement de moitié ses pas plus les
codes longue kobe d'où les codes
symptômes à long terme c'est pour ça une
des raisons pour lesquelles on doit se
faire vacciner pour prévenir la côte est
de long dans certains pays on recommande
déjà une troisième dose de vaccin est ce
que moi aussi j'aurais besoin d'un label
plusieurs études ont montré qu'avec le
temps les anticorps générés par les
vaccins diminue ce qui fait craindre que
notre protection s'estompe
d'autres travaux comme ceux d'andré ce
fim s'ils sont plus rassurants la date
les données suggèrent que le système
immunitaire se met en branle très très
rapidement et il est capable de contrer
le virus est bloqué les formes sévères
et les sources vitalisation dans la
plupart des cas
ultime ans c'est le temps qui dira si
les vaccins perdent en efficacité nos
deuxième dose ont commencé a été
administré à peu près là au mois de mars
et donc on a un recul le plus long qu'on
avait était de l'ordre d'à peu près cinq
mois et des poussières donc on n'a pas
la capacité à ce moment ci de dire dans
douze mois le vaccin protégera à tel
niveau mais pour la période qu'on a
évalué on ne voyait à peu près aucune
diminution de l'efficacité pour
l'instant au québec on recommande une
troisième dose aux gens qui ont un
système immunitaire affaibli et aux
personnes âgées qui vivent en résidence
mais ça n'exclut pas qu'une dose
supplémentaire deviennent nécessaires
pour d'autres parties de la population
c'est un peu nouveau ce concept de à
part la grippe l'aude concept de vaccins
qui vont prévenir des virus d'infections
respiratoires et alors on connaît
peut-être pas la façon idéale de
l'administrer et c'est possible que six
mois plus tard un an plus tard que c'est
normal ça va être normal de recevoir une
troisième d'autres se seraient pas
inédit si je regarde mon carnet de
vaccinations j'ai reçu trois doses de
vaccin contre l'hépatite quatre doses au
moins contre la polio la coqueluche le
tétanos tout des maladies auxquelles
j'ai échappé jusqu'ici
comme à la coved 19 d'ailleurs en
espérant que les vaccins et fasse en
sorte que ça dure
[Musique]